Mà lình với một quan trọng không xin hàng ca mọi người, sớm sợ bình lý mồ phải nớt
và điều quý cùng cho video này là điều quan trọng nhất
sẽ theo video này phải xin sẹt cho các bạn nhé
Được xuống mồn, nó là trước khi học sớm các bạn tổn là sĩ kiểu
về nộng rung biệt tất cứu nha là
Cái cái cáo tệ học biệt tất đấy
Cái đi đầu tiên quá, mình nếu về tuy xin của lý lắm mồn
Này không tổn như xin của lý lắm mồn và vị trách hoạc này là lắm mồn và vị trách hoạc này là lắm mồn và vị trách hoạc này
Vô nơi phát chứa lắm bộnh tế sợi
Chúng ta không tổn như mồn và vị trách hoạc này
mồn tế chứ giờ không tự thức và chỗ độ đó
Gõn gõn gõn gõn bặn mồn và tr raids hợp để hiểu mẩn che
học, chủ rao thấy nắm đ look tí
Tựng nhi trên tựng tựng mồn và chủ đing qua bên đâu
Bây giờ có thể giải quyết tất cả các bạn chóa, nice to high
Bộ điêm nếu như sлет hoai là lạvhy chương xin của lý lươi mồn
đất gí là đặc vô hồng ký mồn và hông liên quanler không quanler
Mình mỗi sắp tới giờ.